greetings my friends and welcome to a
dummy Christmas review let us take a
look at diehard had I heard a timeless
Christmas classic for many of us
diehard is as essential to us as Santa
Claus they both have a large emphasis on
blood red and Germans there's this man
named John McClane who is in a building
that is taken over by German not
terrorists and Snape from Harry Potter
looks at the people it says they are
just here from my name to enter all this
time are just a common thief yes
how's that working out for you that's
certainly very rich yeah there's no
remorse about this you're not even gonna
say you're an exceptional thief by I'm
richer than you now yeah good point
yah so Bruce Willis is sneaking around
the building trying to outwit the German
not terrorists Snape is like sure you
think you're a cowboy you be cut a line
for the movie wow that catchphrase got
ordered a minute of course we partake in
explosions jumping screaming gunshots
probably like a regular Christmas at Ann
Coulter's house but Bruce Willis enlists
the help of the father from Family
Matters
who admits to Bruce Willis that he is
very afraid to hold a gun because he
once shot a kid
that Oracle dweep went too far I will
shoot him too I mean the property damage
that kid cost but at the very end after
all the fighting explosions and shouting
of one-liners for t-shirts Bruce Willis
makes it out alive defeats the not
terrorists Nazis and the family matters
dad even shoots somebody that's right
the happy ending for this Christmas
classic is somebody shooting another
person
I should probably dislike this film
because in many ways it's going against
what everything Christmas stands for
indulging in an entourage of explosion
and violence but simply talking about
this movie has applied testosterone by
20% and my balls have gotten 30% bigger
as a man
I simply cannot denounce it they also
made diehard - which was a pretty good
sequel and three other movies they
pretty much have nothing to do with the
die hard story but Bruce Willis is an
enemy blow shit up so my testicles will
not allow me to denounce it it's hard
sometimes but on the other hand fuck you
it's die hard
he's jittery boom sing don't go away
Christmas I want to stay in this robe